[Musique]
voir les enfants bonsoir bonsoir
mais oui ce soir je vais raconter une
histoire à nikolay a pas trop d'elle une
histoire qu'ils aient beaucoup de buts
et du typique mon échelle
typique du budget
bonsoir
j'ai alors tu nous raconter une histoire
oui une histoire de la petite philippine
et de son lapin blanc d'accord
un instant je me pose
écoutez bien
où est le lapin blot ou et le lapin
blanc pleurer philippines sur la grande
plage
papa maman ou m au lapin blanc le papa
et la maman allongée sur le sable se
faisait bronzer
diby est allé se promener ne t'inquiète
pas il reviendra à ses parents tous les
mêmes je veux tibi et si vous ne mettez
pas le chercher je m'en vais tout seul
je prends le petit chemin et je
retrouverai mon lapin blanc rien et les
philippines partie vraiment tout seul
tout seul avec son tambour
elle prit le petit chemin et rencontra
pokou d'araignée mais pas de l'apa blanc
elle arriva dans un petit port plein de
barques qui s'ennuyait ait choisi la
plus jolie à peine plus grande qu'elle
je ferai le tour du monde mais je
retrouverai mon lapin blanc
elle se mit à ramer très fort et le vent
touche à la barque loin du riad elle
rencontra beaucoup de gros rochers ne
pas de lapin blanc elle rencontrera
beaucoup de petits poissons et des gros
mais pas de l'apa blanc nez des âmes des
petites et des grosses mais pas de lapin
blanc puis la tempête mais toujours pas
de lapin blanc
et elle rencontra heureusement enfin un
énorme bateau qui s'arrêta
et la chasse un matelot très étonné
réussi accueillir philippines juste au
sommet d'une aubade allons vers la plage
dit le commandant du paquebot nous
retrouverons sûrement sa famille et
philippine su ramener chez son papa sa
maman et elle était tellement fatiguée
qu'elle s'endormit
instantanément et voilà les enfants
l'histoire est terminée vous l'avez
aimée
et bien je vous donne le livre merci
chic alors ça nous en fait petit ce
thème qu'a l'action la prison nous
allons y
cher petit
en égrenant chaîne ni bonnes ni les
enfants fait pour eux
[Musique]
tu peux tu débutes du bitume parole mais
c'est le lapin blanc menault patron ce
mois nounours aux propos je vous bien
notre pays allons en route gros phares
serre bonnut les enfants embrasser bien
fort vos parents faites votre toilette
n'oubliez pas de vous laver le don est
fait pour
[Musique]
oh